joining me now with reaction to these
big developments is the attorney for
Michael Flynn Sidney Powell city thank
you so much for joining us I want to go
to that at that point we just made here
because in your filing to say that
somebody is taking a kill shot is is
dramatic in the filing it says the
defense has requested the phone records
of James clapper to confirm his contacts
with Washington Post reporter Ignatius
especially on January 10 2017 when
clapper told Ignatius in words to the
effect of take the kill shot on Flynn
did he actually say take the kill shot
on Flynn I know what do you mean when
you say to the words to the effect of
well obviously I wasn't a party to the
conversation so I am trying to give him
the benefit of the doubt there but yes
we have requested his phone records to
corroborate the timing and everything
about that call that we can possibly
corroborate and it is very concerning of
course there was the leak of the
transcript of the call with kiss lyac at
the same time and then two days after
that the Ignacia story breaks less than
two days actually so there is to me
Sidney where is the evidence then that
that conversation and that those words
or the effect of those words actually
took place I cannot reveal the source
right now but I do have a very good
source for that information and you
believe the Department of Justice is
with Hayes withholding that information
from you I believe the Department of
Justice is withholding a lot of
information as is mr. clapper mr.
Brennan and all of Pete all of the
people who participated in the complete
setup of General Michael Flynn you know
we have found additional text messages
that the government suppressed including
one where agent struck indicates he
knows it's a pretext to go interview
general Flynn they knew there was no
Logan Act violation they exonerated him
completely of being an agent of Russia
by the end of January and yet mr. Comey
still runs to the White House
February 14th and conjures up the entire
obstruction of justice narrative against
the president
when Flynn had been cleared of
everything long before that we also have
information that the agents did
manipulate the 302 you know it was long
in a quote deliberative State as they
called it which is highly unusual in and
of itself we attached as Exhibit 11 to
our document a comparison of the
February 10th in February 11th 302s that
show the addition of substantial
additional claims that were not in there
before and are not supported by the
notes which we also attach as exhibits
to the document so people can go to the
actual document and read it and see a
lot for themselves it's extremely
concerning it's outrageous government
misconduct the agents deliberately
calculated and met to plan and
strategize how to ambush interview
general Flynn without letting him know
he was officially under any kind of
criminal investigation to keep him
relaxed and they wanted to be seen as
Eli's when in fact they knew exactly
what he had said in his conversations
and they intended to create a situation
in which anything he said could be used
against him later as a false statement
without any warnings to that effect
whatsoever and real quickly I've got to
go here but you believe that Lisa Paige
was the one that actually edited the
so-called 302 which is the summary of
the interview with general Flynn correct
well she admitted making some edits of
it I do not know and we do not know yet
until we get the metadata from the FBI
who made the major edits to it that
white Sidney thank you for joining us
here this evening it really is some
shocking developments and we appreciate
you joining us on Hannity to go over
with us thank you